the ancient city of venice italy has
been trying to keep flood waters at bay
for more than a thousand years just this
week the city was flooded
for a while when tides were higher than
expected but now
with a little more warning a recently
completed barrier system has been
activated only on cbs this morning chris
livesay is in venice
with a look at those dikes in action
chris good morning
good morning anthony you know that
during high tide in venice i can expect
to have water
up to my knees but take a look at saint
mark's square
it is dry today and it's thanks to a six
and a half
billion dollar flood prevention system
that's proving
successful now it's far from perfect but
it could be this city's best shot
at survival dickens once said
you'd shed tears to see venice but
overnight
as four feet of tidal sea water try to
engulf the city
it's these 78 retractable dikes that
could almost
make you weep says chief engineer
francesco alsola
is a very
emotional it's called mosaic italian for
moses
and just like in the old testament it's
parting the sea
keeping the adriatic from swallowing its
crown jewel
for centuries it was water that
protected venice from invaders
until it became the invader itself
now these floodgates are the only thing
standing between the exquisite
and extinction last year climate change
and high tides triggered the worst
flooding in more than 50 years
a catastrophe in a city whose lifeblood
is its beauty
a catastrophe this time averted without
the mouse every day more or less every
day is flooded
like a suit of armor yet with chinks it
takes an excruciating
48 hours to activate not enough warning
to thwart a flash flood earlier this
week
swamping saint mark's basilica and
workshops
like paolo brandon's where he's been
carving gondola orlox for 26 years
it doesn't take much does it for water
to come in here
no no no it's just a few inches away he
says
right at the doorstep just like the
global climate crisis
says environmental scientist jane
demasto venice
i think is the canary in the mine
for other places that need to make
very radical choices
about how to survive in the future
for now that radical choice is working
in venice and climate scientists say
that low-lying coastal cities in the u.s
should be paying
close attention places like boston los
angeles
and miami that could be seeing their own
severe flooding
in the coming decades gail yeah we
should be taking notes venice is such a
beautiful city chris i see why people
get emotional about that story
thank you very much